[Music]
out on the out on skinwalker ranch when
you're sitting there for hours
all of that has had stopped there was no
noise whatsoever and this thing was was
motoring north it should have been
rustling and you know leaves and grass
as it went by was maybe
i get i'm guessing about 30 maybe 40
feet away from me it was probably 50
feet away from juliet so we watched this
thing it made a beeline for the the
corner of the abandoned homestead 2 and
went behind it and it was like you know
probably a few seconds later myself and
juliet sort of went right over to try to
follow this thing to get a better view
of it and uh we couldn't see any side of
it we went around the corner of the of
the building turned right and there
there's a sort of a gap between the
corner of the building and as a set of
trees that eventually ends up on the
uh on the track that goes east west on
skinwalker ranch we could not see any
sign of this creature but you know it's
kind of like
the moment in time
uh was pretty short you know maybe
i don't know probably less than 30
seconds when we were looking at this
there was absolute silence and it was
like uh a sort of a version of shock
when you're seeing something like this
and then by the time it got behind the
building i mean
if we had
had the ultimate sort of planning move
into high gear instead of being involved
with this oz effect
we could have got the night vision
binoculars out
we'd search for the creature with night
vision binoculars but we couldn't find
anything but this is an example of
the kind of
thing that happens on skin marker ranch
and yes it is very easy to sit on a
couch or sit on an armchair and say why
the hell didn't you guys you know take
your night vision binoculars out but you
had to be there um you know there are
plenty of instances on skinwalker ranch
when we have captured photographs we
have captured
videos of fast-moving orbs and this kind
of thing we have gobs of photographs of
of these orb-like structures on on skin
marker ranch but that time looking at
this creature you know i you know uh if
i had to do it all over again i would
have had the night vision binoculars a
lot more sort of prepared in my grasp